season nine of Shark Tank kicks off for
the two-hour premiere 8:00 Eastern on
ABC and I've mentioned this before and
I'm not just saying it's because the
gentleman to my right is sitting here I
think it is the most real of the
so-called reality competition shows on
television real people pitching real
ideas to real people with money making
real business deals on the spot and the
man known as mr. wonderful on that show
kevin O'Leary joining me here on the
show in person good to see you sir great
to be here thank you so how did you I
guess get in how did you make your money
for people who may not know your
background
I sold the learning company to the
Mattel toy company back in the late 90s
for 4.2 billion dollars that was the
first of many deals I've had some great
successes that was one of them in great
failures and that's just the nature of
entrepreneurialism you you get some
winners you get some losers but you keep
going I mean how did you hook up with
short time met Mark Burnett was working
on a show with Discovery Channel in
England I flew over to meet with him it
shudders out in you know the beach and
we talked a lot about you know
everything else except Shark Tank but we
came became friends and he said what why
don't we try this and in the first three
years and nobody watched you couldn't
get a dog to watch Shark Tank is that
right and the show was canceled three
years in a row and in the fourth year it
exploded because I think it was timed
with what was happening in the economy
where we were having a major catastrophe
in the financial sector
remember the whole meltdown in the
market and people began to realize that
you know being an entrepreneur is just
as risky as working at a big company and
yet you'll own it and so it became a
powerful supporter of the American dream
like this and you know what are you
watching when you watch Shark Tank
people ask me this all the time you're
watching the pursuit of freedom what
does it mean to be successful in America
you're free and I think that will remain
visceral and powerful and you you know I
can't stop watching it myself and I'm in
it it is really just an incredible watch
because it's genuine it's genuine
because you are definitely competing
against everybody else that's sitting on
to your left and your right that's right
and there are real people with real
ideas with real hopes that quite frankly
you frequently - with your own zest if
you will deal I
I'd say this all the time I'm the only
shark that tells the truth that's the
way I look at it because if you're
encouraging somebody to go pursue an
idea that you know has no merit and
they're going to fail you're just
letting them waste their family's money
and so you know all this kumbaya crap
there's no room for that in business
you're either make it or you don't you
either make money you lose it it's it's
very binary and I can't stand it when
the other sharks say look I'm not gonna
give you any money you keep doing what
you're doing
I'd prefer to say look this is going to
zero and the sooner you take it behind
the barn and shoot it the better yeah
and Cubans sitting on this set - would
you ever want to own a sports team does
that seem like a good business idea to
you to own a sports team you know I've
looked at two deals and and I dug into
them and what I learned about I care
what franchise you're in you can be an
NFL you can be NBA you'll be in the
hockey business yeah the premise is you
buy the team you lose money every year
even if you win the championship and
when you sell it ten years later you get
a massive capital appreciation very few
professional teams actually make money
maybe the original six hockey teams in
those markets the Boston in the Detroit
you know those guys but all the
expansion teams are on the cusp you can
even win a championship in basketball
and make no dough but what's the
franchise value worth when we saw that
LA deal for over a billion dollars for
basketball it just tells you it's all
about capital appreciation so you gotta
have a lot of money that you're willing
to support the losses every year and I
don't necessarily love that you know
because I'm thinking this bubble could
burst one day we're in five years later
the team isn't worth more than it was
five years earlier so which deals did
you look at did you get moving moving
the Phoenix team the hockey team out of
Phoenix to Quebec City that was really
interesting
until Bateman shut it down and I was
willing to be part of that syndicate
it was a really interesting deal I think
you know I don't know if I'm disclosing
something out of school but I think I
purchased prices around 300 and then we
went to the other owners they said not a
chance in hell well if it was $300 I'd
have been in ya know it was you know
what you love about it is you know what
I like to own a professional team
just for the bragging rights of going to
the game and sitting in my box and
saying this puppy's mine but you know
it's great it's a vanity play but it's
totally a vanity play it but you know
when you get to the place in your life
when you can actually afford to do that
you you know I think it's cool I mean I
really worked hard on that one and the
trouble was to make money you got to
move it to a market where you can build
a new stadium and you're gonna have a
ton of corporate support Quebec City it
considers themselves one of the original
[ __ ] six territories yes you know
Montreal Canadiens Boston Bruins in in
hockey that is where the action is and
you get you sell at every game shark
tanks Kevin O'Leary and we'll talk about
beanstalks one of your new apps shortly
here on the Rich Eisen show
Mark Cuban has said he would not buy
stock in the NFL would you yes I would I
think I think every fan wants it you
know let me let me give you an example
of the value of the NFL nobody thought
the London Games would work the biggest
merchandising now the biggest tailgating
every seat sells out in London every
time you take two teams that play over
there the brand is global that tells you
and what is the pinnacle of sports
it's Sunday football do I ever miss a
Pats game never so you know what I like
a piece of the action
yes and so if it was if there was a way
to let fans buy their team like throw
20% out to ownership you'd buy the shows
you'd never saw them you wouldn't even
give a damn what the operating income
was because that's how powerful and
visceral that connection is to your team
why is your connection to the Patriots
would you become a Patriots fan Kevin
you know because I moved to Boston in 92
my kids were born there I got into the
games the whole journey of the Pats and
the trials and tribulations the last
Superbowl best football game in the
history of mankind you know I mean and
it'll be very hard to ever beat that you
remember that third period I was
physically there man in 28 28 3 it was
toast it was over there were guys
leaving the party I was out in Boston
and in their cars turning around and
coming back into where we were watching
it saying I can't beliee
what's happening well people left the
state we were watching paper they
weren't getting back in or not no that's
the whole point is it ain't over till
it's over
and if Brady hasn't taught that listen
to everybody that's why you know I just
like watching him I mean it's I don't
know how long this can go for the guys
40 years old man what an athlete is he
not the best quarterback in history
Kevin O'Leary we'll also that's a
Michigan helmet on my guy that set it on
fire why is that listen we got to
support the team this year this is the
year that I would love to see the Pats
go all the way again one more time with
feeling okay but what's that's a
Michigan Wolverine I understand I want
you to support well I get it Oh get it
but he's now I see what you're saying
yeah did no split no split no no no take
your energy in a different place no but
but I mean Tom Brady in that game set
the record for most prolific passing
performance by a quarterback in the
history of the Super Bowl yes with the
biggest comeback in the history of the
Super Bowl to win the first ever
overtime game in the history of the
Super Bowl to win the most rings by a
quarterback in the history of the Super
it's not enough for me it's over but in
terms of him being a goat he's the
greatest no he is the greatest at all
the crap greed is good you do something
like Gordon Gekko right I want more I
mean the fans are rabid we want more we
want more you go to Boston go to any of
the bars and we want more we wanted to
get you know it's like it's like a drug
soli give it up so you being a big
Boston guy
kevin O'Leary of shark tank one of the
newest members of the shark tank is one
of the most beloved athletes in the
history of Boston sports Alex Rodriguez
your skepticism what is it yeah see you
and I are talking a similar language
right here where I've been like in the
tank I was surprised you know I I was
surprised I competed on a deal with him
and I beat him which I really enjoyed
and so you know I can take a stab at him
right now but he was a pretty good shark
and obviously has a pretty interesting
acumen in business he's very heavily
involved in real estate he understands
return on investment most of these
athletes that come on don't get the
basic principles of investing Rodriguez
was different he really he really nailed
it any was great TV
I mean I think he'll he'll get a lot of
fans on this so which shark do you like
beating the most when you're in the tank
with one of the swells you don't the
shark I really liked the most is mr.
wonderful I love that I will say about
Barbara and I have had an interesting
relationship for years and I always say
this the only reason she gets anywhere
on time including Dancing with the Stars
yes like a son right now Raisa
is because I bought her a new broom oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
my gosh and what is the most lucrative
deal that you've done in the history of
the shark if you have shark do you will
hear about it today okay it will be the
largest exit in Shark Tank history for
the most cash ever a huge deal and I
think it will break today okay
and that's it's perfect timing because
we are this afternoon it's a heavy promo
cycle for season 9 yes and I think it'll
hit the wire right in the middle of our
press cool is that right and it wasn't
time that way okay and we are talking
hundreds of millions of dollars well as
a former ABC and Disney employee to hell
with them let's break it right here I
can't do it
it's sequestered and it's a public
company that's acquiring one of the
shark tank ugly it's huge it's gonna be
this deal is huge all right let's talk
about bean stocks in the meantime tell
me about this app and what people who
might think that they don't have enough
money to invest you know can do with
this app that you're talking about being
stocks is is an app on Android or Apple
that lets you download your phone it's
free mm-hmm but my biggest concern is
like crisscross the country and I'm
teaching engineering classes now these
are some brightest men and women in
America right and I say them okay guys
let's say a third of them are gonna
start a company let's talk about
investing what do you do with with your
own portfolios now how are you investing
for your future because people say oh
it's too scary to invest I'll tell you
what's scary you're 65 you don't have
any investments so I want them to take
him from incremental amounts like 50
bucks 100 bucks put it aside every week
and invest it for the long term and they
say to me how can I invest 50 bucks
apples 150 I can't even buy one share
and that's when it hit me I said what if
I can create an app that lets you buy
fractional shares of stocks and build a
portfolio
20 bucks 50 bucks 100 bucks at a time
here's the math the average income in
America is 52,000 a year the after-tax
you should say whatever I take home I
should take 10 percent invested that's
about thirty five hundred dollars no
bank is interested in helping you invest
thirty five hundred dollars a year but I
care so you download beat stock and it
lets you buy a stock any stock you want
there's a thousand stocks in the
platform and hundreds of ETFs which are
you know bundle of stock like a mutual
fund and put it to work start investing
learn as you watch your portfolio's
value change every day up and down
you're learning about investing that's
why I created Beanstalk and everywhere I
go in America today I tell the kids
download this app set it up and link you
five minutes put in 20 bucks and start
to invest and go to again the Apple App
Store Google Play stores it's available
for for all phones
it's called bean stocks now the EAS t0x
rice bean stocks
Oh sto exit again now you you I'm sure
you've been pitched when people walk on
the street right people walk up to you
and or they just they feel like you're
approachable look every every day and
often I say don't quit your day job okay
well the gentleman over there Mike Dell
2fo and they in the Calloway Hat um he
has what he says is a slammin idea for
an app and I'd love to take a break come
back alright and turn those and Show
studio into a de-facto shark tank you
got it Mike Dell Tufo are you ready to
Rockland and I believe believe in me cab
cannot wait never believed I believed in
you bring it on remember I'm the only
shark that tells the truth so get ready
for the truth wanna kill have you ever
been successfully pitched by somebody
referred to as keV before starting the
pitch would that be a first-hand I would
prefer something with more respect like
mr. wonderful this is gonna be fantastic
kevin O'Leary of shark tank will hear a
pitch on an app from Mike Dell to folk
next here on the Rich Eisen show with
Jerry Seinfeld not far behind
[Music]
okay welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
kevin O'Leary of shark tank and again
beanstalks make sure you go and download
that app right now to make sure that you
can invest smartly despite whatever you
have in your bank account with kevin
O'Leary
are you ready Mike del Tufo yep I'm
ready to go okay
is the microphone on because you're the
audio executive here I'm gonna have
someone all right so for the radio
audience Kevin Oh Larry thank you for
sticking around right here problem I'm
ready mr. wonderful is still sitting in
the guest chair next to my desk on the
dais for Mike Mike del to fo is now
going up two nights don't realize I can
be in front of people when I have an
idea okay that's good focus all my
people over here focus you mr. wonderful
of shark tank right here and ready okay
are you ready Mike del Tufo is standing
in a microphone that's about I'd say 20
feet away
yep looking right at mr. wonderful of
kevin O'Leary of shark tank go for it
Mike del to Fogo hadn't picked on seven
years ago I was I just moved to Santa
Monica in the second apartment I was in
and I'm sitting around who cares get to
the point okay so basically I was a
single guy sitting in the apartment
alone with a couple other people and I'm
like what happens if like something
happens to me and 2,500 miles away my
family's there and they don't know I
could be sitting in the apartment alone
dead for days so I came up with idea for
an app called just in case that would be
basically you download it and you could
check in with this app and other people
could see that a you're alive still you
could basically be tracked with it and
in theory basically it would keep you
you know people knowing what's happening
to you so I mean I started thinking
about it and it came up and basically to
do with kids adults old people there's
30 million people living alone so the
app runs in the background of your kids
phone so you know when every time the
phone turns on you could look at it see
that you've checked just to get the
whole story
yeah for I completely eviscerates you
know apps how how would you make money
doing this
you did a subscription per month people
are gonna pay per month $0.99 per month
very cheap $12 a year okay so here's a
scenario
yuck you're in your apartment you die
don't you think the neighbors are gonna
smell your rotting corpse
oh no there was actually a person in
Santa Monica that's that for eight days
two buildings down for me before people
knew that that person was not only does
this have zero merit I mean the chance
that people actually want to contemplate
their mortality and pay 99 cents a month
doing it is crazy no don't quit your day
job absolutely there's no way it could
happen no not a chance
no so this is like this is like a did
that find your iPhone no find your
iPhone would not let you know think
about it if you're if your mom calls you
for two days and doesn't get an answer
she's probably gonna call the super say
go check on his corpse like think about
it they don't need 99 cents of money in
that when you want whit if it's
something you don't have to do no I
won't care there'll be a new guy oh so
right won't work at all no chance at all
okay good try mine tried try some nice
parting gifts for you mom do I get for
playing what do I get I want to know
what I get
where does that rank in terms of ideas
that you you've been pitched pretty well
at the bottom that's the worst night one
of the you know maybe a chance to bring
Mike on Shark Tank with this let me
check in with the policy I wish I would
love to see that moment in the bright
lights when he pitches this please on
the other hand Barbara may invest you
know yeah so basically that's like a
human being GPS jack some bottom line is
at the end of the day how does he know
you're dead the app doesn't know you're
dead you'll have a helot you're not yeah
I would tell you yeah you're not
checking in every time you unlock your
phone it would ping and you put people
on a list that know that it's like
you're your mother is in Florida she
could be sitting in the house you know
that at least he's checked in on our
phone if you're there kid
you don't have to talk to him on the
phone you know if the calm and if it's a
kid you know the kid if you think you're
if you're if you're worried
why don't you call her well let's say
Mike let's let's assume that you you
don't you're not gonna call people don't
call their mother and father 25 on your
mom's mom I I just want to make sure
you're not dead like are you kidding you
should call your mother every day
no no I'm talking about like all day you
don't know oh you want to know the exact
moment you're - yeah exactly
she logs on says I'm dying I'm dying
like you know Mike maybe should call it
I'm not dead yet calm there you go see
we're shopping where were shopping
shopping I know they're really bad
really bad I tried Oh God he said on
this idea for seven years check on the
corpse of that idea thank you for coming
on Kevin really Celeste again I love
what you do and how you go about it and
that show is Shark Tank is awesome and
beanstalks everybody should check it out
on the Apple and Google Play Store so
thanks for coming very much really enjoy
you got it Kevin all the area of Shark
Tank again the season nine to our
premiere is Sunday October 1st the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to